on va faire un jeu on va jouer à
l'interview bigard le steak haché où les
deux puisqu'il ya le steak haché bidart
également lola quand on te parle de
bigard tu penses direct à jean marie
mais il ya des gens ce qu'ils pensent
aux steaks hachés wi fi gharbi ça alors
je vais tout donner des observations tu
devras me dire selon toi si ça concerne
jean marie un stack est chaste à cacher
ou les deux il a 5 % de matière grasse
bigard le steak haché ou les deux les
steaks hachés bye bye la main peu plus
la matière et non sur gaza il peut être
cuits en cinq minutes bigard le steak
haché où les vous le partager facilement
bigard le steak haché où les deux os les
steaks hachés n'est pas très partagés
cyril d'accord très bien c'est bien il
partage pas jean marie roy thème avec
moi c'est difficile c'est même moi on le
trouve souvent dans un bistrot bigard le
steak haché ou les deux
[Rires]
eo2 il est indigeste non c'est le steak
haché
ouais il faut pas qu il faut avoir un
goût d'oignons bigard le style sa
compagne très bien d'un voire de
plusieurs verres de vin rouge bigard le
steak haché où les deux ans les délais
il est tendre et même parfois un peu mou
bigard le stade
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vous deviez on a en embrasser un
maintenant là tout de suite de manière
sensuelle ce serait bigard et s'est
caché ou les deux chasses à cacher aussi
un bigard
[Musique]
mais ça c'est dit facile 10 des couples
qui sont ensemble depuis aussi longtemps
que nous sert depuis 13 ans normalement
ils s'embrassent plus vraiment très
goulûment mais vous vous embrasser coup
du moment c'est pas trop où j'en avais
tellement fouillé que la langue et tout
[Musique]
moment ça passe quoi ses plus hautes des
liens n'ont jamais été son délire
d'accord prévient aime pas trop à jean
rault le ruling peine comme un
adolescent va répond ouais bah tanger et
et cunnilingus
si les trous de balle d'argent à berlin
j'étais doublure dernier moment par un
allemand parce que ma partenaire a
éternué mais il lui fallut